ben altri ragazzi veramente questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi finalmente dopo sei
mila anni che dovevo farlo facciamola
videos nintendo lato è uscito da un
pochettino
però io è da un po che ci gioco lo avete
visto nelle sto di vista che non è
quindi volevo farvi vedere un po come
funziona e come diventare ingegneri ci
penso io
quindi ragazzi andiamo direttamente
scatolare il primo kit all'interno primi
primi troviamo ovviamente il gioco
a seguire ci sono i fogli di cartone per
creare ovviamente tutte le gli accessori
che possiamo
io nella mia vita non sono riuscito mai
neanche a creare un aereoplanino di
carta quindi non so però proviamoci non
si somma partiamo con il primo toy con
da costruire che dovrebbe essere questo
il verde
in realtà per costruire queste cose ci
sono più fogli questo è un foglio solo
quindi perché dovrebbe essere il più
semplice se non riesco a fare mango
questo ciao ciao dovrebbe essere
abbastanza semplice seguendo le
istruzioni che ci sono sulla switch io
appoggio il mio chat ed indica comunque
suolo seguiamo tutorial passo passo onde
evitare di costruire una cosa che non
c'entra niente io sarei veramente capace
di questo
[Applauso]
ok poi spiega perbene lungo la linea in
piegatura pirate spiegando tutto capito
dice l'amore che fa quando piero
[Musica]
la macchina è finita
è stato più semplice del previsto adesso
devo fare l'antenna
[Musica]
ho finito la easy a questo e controller
per controllare una macchinina proviamo
a vedere se funziona perché se non
abbiamo fatto tutto sto casino per
niente ma in teoria dovrebbe funzionare
momento
[Musica]
e poi aumentare l'intensità
diminuire l'intensità del casinò
provocato dalla macchina
[Musica]
e tutta questione di allenamento e
poteri psichici oppure se quei
semplicemente la mia ma non lo so potete
guidarla anche senza la patente
e passiamo prossimo direttamente alla
moto rispetto al foglio di prima e c'è
un po ci sono delle cominciamo ragazzi
[Musica]
non c'è tutta la questione di piegare i
pezzi di nuovo
[Musica]
ho fatto questo pezzo che non ho capito
che cos'è però vabbè è un pezzo della
manopola comunque il tutorial era una
bomba pazzesca solo che se non lo segue
alla lettera dischi di fare un casino
quindi va seguito alla lettera pro
veramente figo
ok ma dove serve questo paga è veramente
una piega non è difficile però che
richiede una certa dose di ingegno cosa
che modestamente gli ovetti funziona che
il tasso del clacson
va bene sono riuscito a fare la prima
bisogna manopola e è venuto bene c'è
questo entrare dovrebbe essere la mano
sinistra un boom della moto adesso manca
quella destra poi manca tutto il pezzo
che faremo ovviamente però con la magia
dell'editing sarà molto più rapido del
previsto un mazzo e non pensavo così
figo è bellissimo perché ritorna pure
indietro
una volta inseriti i giochi con
all'interno del mondo
spero di stare calmo andiamo sul gran
premio difficile se stiamo subito il
nostro agente aggeggio gadget toy con
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e vabbè pronta competitività in mostra
tra tutte la pace il freno cosa che non
lo dirò mai nella mia vita
via via che sono secondo sono quasi
primo mamma mia
signori
è arrivato secondo ah ho capito perchè
sono arrivato secondo
la ragazza secondo ragazzi perché per
arrivare primo bisogna personalizzare la
propria moto
l'ex con vento leggero
proviamoci direi che possiamo passare
alla fase di personalizzazione del toy
con che se poi ovviamente personalizzate
la moto va più veloce
ci sono diversi modi per personalizzare
i propri autori con uno di questi è
tramite il kit che potete prendere di
nintendo lavo direttamente oppure con il
vecchio classico pennarello e direi che
la prima personalizzazione di oggi la
facciamo con questo
e stata una cosa molto fantasiosa
una volta finito col pennarello passiamo
alla scatola dei sogni
all'interno sono un miliardo e mezzo di
adesivi va bene direi che la prossima
volta con queste personalizzazioni sono
sicuramente più veloce se per ora
passiamo al robot
direi che possiamo passare al pezzo
forte è almeno quello che io penso sia
il pezzo forte perché la cosa che tra
tutte mi piace di più che è
quindi ragazzi abbiamo all'interno
dell'asse del kit anche questa volta il
gioco come sempre
dopodichè ci sono tutti i nostri non lo
so poi vedremo e poi abbiamo i fogli per
costruire il nostro il nostro robot sono
tanti però lo facciamo
direi che ci rivediamo tra un po tempo
un attimo
anzi aspetta le uniche o non ci deve
comica pronti sotto la scrivania ma che
dite
ma cosa insinuate
dei bebè quindi ragazzi una volta che ci
siamo vestiti e armati siamo pronti per
testare il nuovo gioco
sì però se uno deve giocare ho capito o
no ragazzina vicino adesso no adesso non
posso avere rischia casa via formando
sta provando a giocare ha centrato così
arriverà a distruggere tutto questo è
comunque se sei uno schifoso cioè di un
e divertire da solo essere senza nemmeno
avvisare sarà sociale mi conosci abusivo
lì quasi poi la macchina
mi fai resa toschi v.le la gente e non
stava invece così semplicemente sono
modalità che faccio le cose da poco
prima volta la prima volta su giocando
non mi farà rispondetemi prima ultima
cosa
la modalità in prima persona poi hai
capito che fa ma che poi non è possibile
che tu allora questa cosa successione
con l'elettrodinamica composta certo che
se tour a soli per bene non toccare
adesso sento di fare bene se no va beh
semplicemente ci sono dei cosi dei dei
catarifrangenti primo contatto
all'interno che se tu fai così cliccato
tende al limite e il sensore del gioco
no sono lino rileva
e straniera più semplice capire la
singolarità del booking e se veramente
lo chiedevo io mi dice lo zio basta
tirare e per andare avanti non si fa era
farina
[Musica]
non potere maniera giusta camminare ma
loro no fermo lì ferma lì federico
stamani anche se loro filo possa
aggiustare con lo scotch non è un
problema quindi non preoccupatevi se
avete amici bisonti tipo questi però non
toccare perché devo spiegare come
funziona se tu lo tiri vedi che sale qua
fosse arrivato io direi no grazie
se almeno al momento giusto baidu
presenterà già all olio
no grazie
[Musica]
qualcuno glielo spiega che senza la
schedina non funzionano
[Musica]